ladies and gentlemen you're going to
want to stay for the discussion
man is there a lot to talk about in this
episode rewind
i am low-key bloated right now
speaking of low-key we're going gonna
watch episode
four today see how i did that hilarious
joke guys i love it when you hit the
subscribe button if you enjoy our video
and also if you enjoy our video
hit that like button i appreciate all of
you who
serve your glorious purpose by becoming
patronage
where we got the full-length
watch-alongs for loki over there we
cover a bunch of other shows but
honestly guys what i really want to
mention on a sincere note is the channel
late to the party that's right greg's at
it with another reaction channel
shout out in the intro robert and
vanessa have been uh great friends of
mine for quite a while
and they only recently were able to quit
their jobs and fully commit to doing
youtube full-time and
while they're called late to the party
they still manage to get their loki
reactions
up before hours and they get access to
the episode an
hour later than us every time guys i
really love if we could help push them
to over a hundred k subscribers yeah
let's let's see if they think it's nice
that i
shouted them out you know because i want
the i want the credit for being nice i
think they're gonna be like i don't need
your pity shout out
greg we got here all on our own also for
thom thank you so much for
uh editing these highlights down for us
your hustle
is very much appreciated
some people saw that episode and said it
was filler isn't that hilarious
it's uh more divisive than i expected it
to be well don't you know that five
seconds of loki mentioning that he's
bisexual cost them 130 thousand views
oh man all the people who just unplugged
their disney
accounts after that
hey now hey now
it's good to see you again swoops
towards the palace that valkyrie flies
over defeats the dragon
and saves ourselves oh snap diggity
there's our variant
what whoa i hereby arrest you for crimes
against the sacred timeline oh it's
sylvie origins
so she was a variant her whole life her
whole life
[Music]
did they just not explain to her parents
no
they'll figure it out or maybe when they
reset it like in a
timeline appropriate loki appears or
something
next case
next case right here
[Music]
fascinating that was a bad day this is
personal for her
[Music]
where are we where we gone she hit the
top floor
[Music]
this one elevator door guards the time
keepers
oh snap there goes those theories
yeah we'll see they're all king to
conquer
his eyes man all we saw is glowing eyes
still the time keepers are all that
stand between us and full-scale calamity
but if they want me to find loki in the
variant
i need access to one or c20 i'm sorry
but that's impossible
she could have information
okay the variant she enchanted c20
scrambled her mind i nobody does
we don't want people to panic this is a
perfect time to panic
what a beautiful apocalypse i know
perfect time for a trailer shot
everywhere and every when i went caused
a nexus event
because i'm not supposed to exist
until eventually i figured out where to
hide and so that's where i grew up
the ends of a thousand worlds
now that's where i'll die
no no
it says shot from the trailer everyone
thought it was black widow
any news on c20 no we need to find them
i've have incredibly distraught too
human emotions coming out
wow
kiss we've got something
no i mean no did you get them
wow oh man to be there or just to watch
the apocalypse but survive it
there you go
i got uno prediction that a lot of
people got
the tva is lying to you put them in
how horrible seriously
[Music]
go away
you did this what oh
i hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be
a bad memory prison how quaint
very
who else are we gonna see you conniving
craving pathetic
worm you did this oh
no no you deserve to be alone and you
always will be
[Music]
okay eventually you'll learn to block it
loki
time lives how lovely
dormammu i have come to bargain so i
thought maybe i'd interview the other
variant
oh no she's just too dangerous too
dangerous
come on roman this is what i do and this
is what i do nobody speaks with that
variant
you know we brought in cree titans
vampires why is it the two
orphaned vampires little blades
sprinkled in there yeah
played mobius oh did loki say anything
while you were in there so the tv is
lying to me
why oh it's gonna click with her just
doing my job
yeah it's your key to talking to the
lady
please i beg you i'm a horrible person
i can't if your hair because i thought
it'd be funny
i crave attention i'm a i'm a narcissist
yeah it's because i'm scared of being
alone
okay loki you ready to talk this guy
name in the groin enough you know yeah
yeah i'll tell you how to hear what
yeah look at scenario you know smashes
nuts a few times
she's difficult and irritating and she
tries to hit me all the time
i love her my partners know yeah i guess
you know a new partner like life
partners maybe
something very very big is going to
happen and when it does
i'll dispose of her well we saved you
the trouble there
she's already been pruned so assume i
do set you free exactly what did you
just say what the variant
she's gone not before she took out two
of ours oh mobius you're good
good riddance good interrogation
you're crying loki
i'm so funny it's like look at your eyes
you
like her
[Laughter]
two variants of the same being
especially
you forming this kind of sick twisted
romantic relationship
that's pure chaos that could break
reality it's breaking my reality right
now
what a incredible seismic narcissist
you fell for yourself hell yeah
is that with an i.e or just an eye is
she alive
for now
if what sylvie told me about this place
is true it affects all of us
here we go now you you've already told
me about 50 lies in the past 10 minutes
i'm not lying this time
you're all variants oh no everyone who
works at the tva
the timekeepers didn't create you they
kidnapped you from the timeline
so before this you had a past maybe you
had a family maybe you had a justice
cake
nice try no let's get it to you yeah
you know all the liars in this place
you're the biggest
why because i lied about your girlfriend
oh no that i can respect i mean the lies
you tell yourself
burn mobius burn
[Music]
she's got questions she's got memories
[Music]
come with me well this took a turn i
wasn't expecting
if you could go anywhere anytime where
would it be
i can go anywhere anytime you know what
i mean why wouldn't you let me
interrogate sylvie
i told you we couldn't risk her escaping
again she wouldn't have escaped
the other variant got away during your
first interrogation didn't he
that's another wilson line
when did you first notice what was going
on with c20
she seemed fine when when i when i saw
her i mean a little freaked but fine
well she quickly wasn't fine okay okay
what are you gonna do with that trophy
oh is that gonna go you're right
sly devil how's that looks
perfect when you were in my head i saw
something
what did you do to me i can't create
memories
and only use what's already there
timekeepers took your lives from you
your variants with a safe
[Music]
shelby
oh
[Music]
i looked happy you're always so mad
these days
you're not hearing me
real what i saw this is a place that
i've been i lived
down there i went to that bar i had
friends calm down i'm
variant oh damn obvious
oh she had to lean in and hands
no no bs
what are you doing passing the time do
you care about this barrier sylvia i'm
not sure if care is the right word i
think we've covered this back here
let's go
do you swear she didn't implant those
memories in hunter c20 maybe it's no
i believe her so i just have to trust
the word of two loki's
[Laughter]
[Music]
and if you want to save her you need to
trust me can we do that
yes
oh hell now i think you have something
of mine
[Music]
you know where i go if i could go
anywhere wherever it is i'm really from
and wherever i had a life before the tva
came along
have you had a jet ski that's what i'm
like to do
oh hell no no no better not no
what the [ __ ] no come
on no there
better be a second mobius like
everyone's theorized that breaks my
heart
i can't believe this
oh what a shot
son of a [ __ ] oh i'm so bad
i just i i'm so excited hole in my chest
damn it
who was in here with her sorry man b-15
insisted
are you going down put out an alert for
hunter b-15
[Music]
this feels like a tragedy yeah i've got
them from here
do you remember me i do
what do you want to say to me varian why
did you bring me in
i don't remember
top brass
[Music]
gracious timekeepers holy [ __ ] as
promised the variance
you've arrived
[Music]
always oh yeah
[Music]
now
[Music]
get her sylvie i finished the job
[Music]
a lot of lightsaber love in the sound
design of that fight
[Music]
of course we know they're robots
[Music]
they are oh damn that's why you gotta
ask on the way in
okay
what so what just said are they gonna
introduce robots to us
oh my god it's crazy mindless androids
it never stops i thought this was it
someone else is that i was like no not
gonna happen
i have to tell you something we will
figure this out
how do you
this is new for me um
i hope she reciprocates
[Music]
oh oh god please do it
what
okay so they can't kill them it's got to
like trash
yeah drop them in a bin somewhere
do it no you're gonna tell me
everything oh
damn oh damn
nipple chills
chili nips oh chili chili nips
okay so that was not a filler episode
that was definitely a filler that was
that was the filler here
waste of my time
of course we did the obligated let's
wait to see if there's a p
credit scene oh yeah p.o no okay
was i was like maybe maybe mobius isn't
dead because i'm like
that must transfer them somewhere right
i can certainly see it being
the case and then unless it happened uh
freaking tom hiddleston i'm like
okay definitely transfer them somewhere
well and
i don't know with the revelation that
this is some kind of weird robo
conspiracy of some kind i
i almost wonder if the power if the
scope of power isn't so grand that it
can just vaporize you yeah maybe it just
teleports you
yeah i don't think it's like um you know
robot construct it's just that the
well the time keepers or androids or
someone else really and something else
really in charge yeah it's like if
somebody had that godly of a power they
wouldn't need this
this front of amusement park
animatronics to run their thing or to
appear as though it's running their
thing you know
there's some reveals in that one damn
yeah this is a big episode
vampires yeah yeah whatever they talked
about here is cool but what they set up
for the future
oh that's what matters i can't wait till
ten movies from now not
so much next week's episode
wow hell yeah it's just so funny with
the robot question someone asked us
very recently i'm like um but do you
think that actually
immediately no definitely not we're not
gonna get any of that in the show
they specifically said it because of the
android mentioning yeah
oh the timekeepers are answering and at
first it was like this is kind of a
random question this is one
this is hell am i dead
not yet but you will be
unless you come with us
[Laughter]
and that's why channels like heavy
spoilers and new rock stars exist
oh they could tell us oh it's going to
be like a 90 minute breakdown
all they are yeah every every loki's
coming to the show let's have a super
short brief discussion about this
okay let's get the first things out of
the way
i yeah i think it's king i think it's
getting king
conker yeah ravana rensselaer confirmed
villain
and we know her connections to king lava
the way you the way you do that just
sends shivers up my spine
we know king the conqueror is coming at
least an ant-man
yeah we've already seen a glimpse of his
city in the quantum realm
so and uh it seems likely it's king
especially with the position that ravona
rensselaer seems to hold in this
organization and she seems to be the
gatekeeper for like
all information so and then we didn't
look this up at all
it just came to our heads naturally top
of my head i recognized
richard grant's face we were like that's
classic low-key
and that's definitely both loki but
redesigned
redesigned a little bit yeah i was
pretty surprised by just how well we
knew that instantly
and did not quickly look that up while
we were setting up the microphones
and i would like credit for not being
upset that they changed him to a black
guy
that's it that's the review
this is my intent right here just to
derail everything with the sage joke
this is the show like falcon in the
winter soldier but this one lately
especially has been getting so much
like the controversy stuff is so like
not controversial i know at all and not
just these videos i just pop up in my
feed i'm just like
marvel's not even hiding
i'm like this whole show is about people
realizing that the paradigm they exist
under is a lie
that's built to like oppress them from
living their true life
we're not going to make the discussion
about that it's just so funny just
it's like the littlest things people are
making these
huge dramatic videos out of that's right
anyway
uh yeah so there's those things um which
i'm excited to see fully fleshed out and
explored
in the next episode young avengers has
got to be coming man they got kid loki
here yeah man
they got the little uh you know uh
wicked and speed i almost said like baby
quicksilver
we got wiccan and speed looking speed
and eli bradley
bishop is coming yeah yeah man there's a
lot eli bradley yes
so yeah we got that going but i really
i really thought this was a really cool
episode i've talked with a lot of people
and i've heard like varying opinions on
this like i don't i'm running circles
where everyone's like this is a perfect
show
and one one thing i've heard um
mention i won't say who they did talk
about how they wish this show was
hopping around a lot more places since
that is the ability of it
but it really dawned on me in like this
episode that's just all the tva and a
couple of other
locations like yeah but i really like
how like
this is the set of the show yeah yeah
yeah it's really more
it could go that massive but i like
these like dialogue driven scenes where
you really get character things to do
because that's like the richness of this
show to me
like everything they've done with sylvie
is
really fascinating stuff he's got an
amazing origin story
i know right dan that's heartbreaking
yeah taken as a child
because yeah that was a question that uh
was brought up in the last episode we
were watching was like was she just
born ovarian because she said she's been
running from them her whole life and
then they confirmed it here that she was
just taken as a child
and when she's in the uh elevator
with ravono rinslayer and she's asking
her
like what is my what is the reason you
took me what was my nexus event
i don't know i don't i don't even know
your name yeah
i don't know who you are
what would you ask i'm sorry yeah yeah
yeah
so all that all this work the the thing
that like traumatized her the most the
one thing that she just
has been dying to know the answer to you
know like in her she's under the
impression she's about to die
yeah this is all she wants to know what
was it for can't even get that cathartic
satisfaction
in her what she believed to possibly be
her
final moments man it's cold
but like the littlest scenes are so good
b-15 in this episode forgive me for not
knowing
um anyone else's name in the show
besides tom hills
but b-15
love seeing this layer of her one
question did pop this is a nitpick this
is a this is a real nitpick of mine um
when i say
nitpick i really want to underline that
we need a nitpick
graphic um because there are some things
where i'm like no i got a criticism
this is a nitpick because i could see
answers to why he didn't do this and i
could see answers to why he should have
done this
he was so curious about c20
and i was like why didn't why don't you
talk to why don't you talk to b15 about
this
because b15 was enchanted too and she
had a similar experience like
you know wouldn't you want to like even
check up on b15 and make sure she's not
going to deteriorate if any of what
ravana rensselaer are saying happens to
be true
or maybe you can get answers to what
you're looking for through maybe
trying to understand a little bit of
what she might have experienced you know
i just thought that with owen wilson
being the analyst
character in here and is so
investigative on
this specific subject of like her mind
just she seemed fine i don't understand
i thought he would have asked her that's
a little thing
but with b15 i i loved her performance
here
but my favorite moment from her is
something that's just
so simple um but so so do you know what
moments i'm about to go to john
it it's got to be the moment in the rain
the rain
tears in the rain or whatever that song
from uh blade runner is
it was like a blade runner moment it
really was uh uh what's
what's that freaking guy's name rucker
howard yeah it was
damn you're right good call and there
are some very obvious
inspirations from blade runner at times
oh yeah and
having uh having that moment like it
just it's so moving to me just watching
an actor's performance not doing any
flashbacks just keep the camera on her
just let her do the job let her
experience her
life and realize what a lie she's living
currently
i was i looked so happy i looked happy
you know it brought tears to my eyes
i know that was touching it was very
touching stuff yeah
she's great i mean she's a stand-up
stand-up hero in this one stand-up
comedian
she showed up man i'm trying to take on
everyone yeah dude well this that's the
funny thing to me about this episode is
because this episode had so many
wonderful quiet character dialogue
moments
and like last week was mostly that and
it seems like there was a certain
division as to whether people think that
was worthwhile or not but i love that
this one
dialed up all the kookyness that we've
been waiting for and all the reveals and
all the sort of crazy stakes
but also was really pinned together by a
bunch of
really effective emotional scenes oh
that's what makes the show so damn good
yeah yeah
despite what some channels are saying of
where all they care about is virtues
what are you talking about yeah and they
clearly watch the show too
definitely so paying close attention for
those easter eggs
um because i i did love how the like the
first half and the last half feels so
different
it really seems like it's it's just like
this momentous build too
uh mobius is gonna investigate but he's
got a friendship with loki he's gonna
figure out
he's gonna figure it out he's gonna
start believing him so he gets you going
he gets you so then when he's
when he walks in there with that
intensity like we're about to
break the hell out of this place yeah
i'm about to break the whole freaking
again
yeah we're gonna team up hop into
portals in time everywhere you know
we could be on the run together
apocalypse after apocalypse till we
figure this thing out you guys gotta
fall in love man we're gonna
punch all of this the scene felt like
yeah and then the next scene he's done
he's uh it's he's uh what's that what's
the word they use john i rely on you for
word
memorization oh he's uh he's pruned
pruned
yes yeah he's he's pruned in that very
in that very next scene i'm like damn
i it was it's weird i wasn't like
even close to being brought to tears
there
yet i was so mad your heart is
crushed i was pissed because i was like
i was like it was a conflicting feeling
of i'm pissed at the show for doing that
but i don't criticize the show it's
not what i want at all but i accept it
as
drama yeah that's a hundred percent the
feeling
like i am so mad right now in this
moment
it would have happened because because i
was so excited about oh what's the calm
is this the crazy [ __ ] that was teasing
yeah
the exciting adventure and yes this is
where we wanted mobius to be he's on the
other side he realized he's a variant
but damn uh and like for for a
miss because he's not really dead like
he can't be if loki's not dead moby
there can be another moby
if he's i feel like this mobius will
come back or
if not at very least another mobius will
turn
well i'm not sure the pruned is like
eliminating the soul
yeah it seems like being like i don't
know i i assume based on that
post-credits scene that if loki woke up
in an alternate location then so did
mobius
yes anybody else would which would be
fantastic and i believe that to be the
case
speaking another tv because if it was
just an actual death
i might be a i might actually lean
towards a little bit more uh
critical of the show itself of like but
there's so much going on
around this moment and moby's such a
such a grand character like you should
have had time to really sink
into the feeling of oh moby has died so
i would
i would be there with the show yeah but
i don't actually believe he's dead
you would be wanting that proper
send-off if yeah that was the case he's
like what the hell man just lasted like
30 seconds
yeah exactly you just brought him back
after like a whole episode away what
gives
yeah because i love when a show can mess
with my emotions like that
how you it feels like it's ramping up to
this
oh no and then you get something just
completely [ __ ]
weird in the end where they go to meet
the time keepers
and the scene was playing like this is
the finale episode so i was like
there's some mislead coming like you
could feel that there's a mislead coming
yeah in that moment
but it did feel like a very climactic
episode i almost shouted that out i was
like this does feel like we're getting
to the finale or something
yeah and it was playing it was being
played so by the numbers the way it was
going like the time peepers had
um incredibly generic dialogue
you know they were the they were and i
don't mean this in uh
uh in the moment i was critical of it
but once you learn who they are i'm like
okay i wasn't getting off shaggy what's
going on
it was all generic yeah exactly because
they're a car they're a theme park ride
yes they will soon be in disney world
they evoked like the
the 80s sci-fi villains maybe think of
bill and ted
like they look great but they did move
kind of weird yeah i was like this is
some weird mixture of practical and cgi
they're like the floating robe guys
trying to run the future but yeah yeah
it was funny because i it they looked
like cg creations but it seemed like
they also animated them to be kind of
stiff and rich yes and also knowing that
there's
two more episodes coming and uh you're
like okay there's definitely some
mislead
thing happening that's about to be set
up for and um
so yeah when they when they had them is
my first thought is it's probably king
the conqueror
it's probably kang uh as we've all been
sort of saying this whole time because i
was like oh [ __ ] the time keepers are
real like
that you actually caught me because
we've been saying the time here is
probably unreal yeah
and then the show here i'm like damn i
guess they're real
it's kind of disappointing how they're
actually behaving oh no wonder it's
disappointing because this is supposed
to just it's a mislead yeah
and it's psyching you out because this
is not the truth but ravona
she didn't seem weirded out by the fact
that they are
a.i or uh yeah she didn't seem like
what no all my beliefs have been
shattered
you know yeah she like she didn't even
have like a
response really to it it's like she knew
so
that to me supports more that king the
conqueror is definitely
uh it's gotta be yeah and i mean she's
so protective of anything it seems like
she is the gatekeeper to the timekeepers
and she's so protective of like every
aspect of
what's going on with this case and so it
would certainly seem as though
yeah whoever's got the real orders she's
taking
them you know and now so that's uh
that's the big part she's got ravonna
now
and then loki's in this other random
timeline
it's apocalypse where i'm assuming we're
gonna get like that loki running for
president homage yeah
that's the timeline we'll get it but uh
uh what was the there's another really
cool part of this episode that i really
wanted to touch on that i'm not
remembering at 2 am right now
but it was a damn good part of this
episode okay okay okay
well let's well while we talk let's get
my criticism sometimes
some criticisms out of the way i thought
the fight scene could have been cooler
at the end
yeah it needed to be great but i was
like
this really isn't good choreography this
is just an edit
salad not that yeah i'm like this is
like cw
television fight scene i'm looking at
here
like the early cw shows except better
camera movement
so yeah i thought like that could have
been cooler in some way
not that i'm expecting to be expert
martial artists but
also i'm kind of expecting them to be
some martial arts because
it's like loki and sylvie and the
minutemen who are specifically like the
people you send in to handle the job
yeah they seem like they should have
access to every fight
style in the known universe yeah so they
speak every language in the known
universe you know
so it's not a storytelling problem it's
more of a technical problem i have with
like the capturing of a fight scene like
is really wasn't like
as cool as as i would kind of expect it
to sort of look
yeah um so yeah there's that
uh the freaking nexus event
of them like falling for each other that
i was trying to remember yeah
yes please john take it away oh yeah you
remembered i mean i'm curious to know
wow how people out there are going to
respond to that because for me like
i was kind of rooting for that just
because of how like sort of
this this show does remind me in a lot
of ways of rick and morty as
as if it was not about somebody as like
nihilistic and self-centered but you
know as
like i don't know there's something very
very
uh cheeky and fun to me about them
falling for each other because who could
understand
loki better than like the most
misunderstood loki possible and yeah
that like
bond whatever that is creating this
super strong like you know
it doesn't arc off the timeline it just
shoots off straight into you know the
red line and so like i don't know that
seemed
i i wonder what that's going to pay off
into because part of me doesn't really
expect that it'll be like a traditional
loki selfie romance or something like
that but i didn't get the vibe that
sylvie was into him
not as much i was ready for a a
joke to happen of he tells her how he
feels
which i love that he's really into her
like i love that
like that when he's talking with mobius
and getting defensive for her
scared that she died yeah i really like
that scene a lot and i and i love uh
how uh how much of a rise it got out of
him yeah
so yeah but i was expecting in the final
moment
where she's just oh or something yeah i
don't know some dumpster coming
i hate loki's yeah you know
but the thing is that because
the the word narcissism came up quite a
bit in this particular episode and while
i would
you know say loki's definitely a
narcissist um
so tony stark and a lot of other great
heroes
it's one of those qualities that
describes you narcissists are
charming on television and movies they
portrayed as characters
frustrating as hell to be around
so yeah uh uh
i don't view it as and i feel like some
people will might take it that way of
like
loki just being in love with himself i'm
like that's not it what are you talking
about that's the whole point of that
it's on the surface that's supposed to
appear that way but yeah but that's kind
of the whole point is that all these
people who they decide are variants
are still people they're individuals
with souls and lives and different
experiences
so while they might be like genetically
a similar thing or whatever yeah they're
they're not even that
they're they're different people yeah so
you know it's like
sylvie is clearly very different
than loki you know it's complete they're
completely different people
so it's not like he's falling in love
with himself but yet
through their experiences they they can
identify best with one another
yeah yeah one they stand and they stand
in the face of an organization that
stan that basically asserts that there
is only one acceptable version of you
yeah and so like we found that oh man
both of us were deemed unacceptable and
yet that is kind of the key to us having
this
unlikely and very unique bond you know
yeah
insight into one another's souls i would
love to date
loki loki seems like a very fun
other you just keep shifting into
different people to
spice things up yeah yeah yeah yeah you
shift into sylvie and make it really
interesting for you
you could uh you could take it one step
further you could have loki
like enchant your mind and just you know
oh damn yeah do all
make you know consensually have you do
all kinds of things
wow you're a freak i'm kinky for loki
that's my kink
give me all the loki silvia sandwiches i
hope that they all
every loki in this next episode in this
dimension you know they all just getting
a big you know hirogasm yeah should be
the end of the
boys yeah i want to beat the boys to the
punch
because they're already memes on twitter
i'm sure of homelander and homelander
together
um and lady sifts in this too guys isn't
it
she pulverized his nuts i'm glad you
came back for a cameo
and while she did seem to serve a moment
of reminding loki
like it was a weird thing of this label
that loki is assigned yet it seems like
he's accepted it about himself
like i'm always going to be alone i'm a
narcissist
this is who i am but i also want love
and connection
you know he's he's in recovery he is
he's maintaining his recovery by
acknowledging his reality he's really
been
stripping down loki in in this show you
know and they've really been stripping
him down
only only literally once though which is
a bummer i know because he's got a great
body he does yes
he does they should choke that more so
yeah
uh loki um loki having that interaction
with lady siff
a part of me on just a on a completely
different level
like ladies if i feel like should be a
character that's been that should be
much more elevated by this point in the
mcu
yeah and she's not in ragnarok and she's
fine i don't know she's did she
appear in shield agents of shield uh her
sister does i
i can't remember if sif herself does or
not i don't know if she does but either
way
it means the shield seems to be some
other variant so
um yeah i was excited at her coming back
because i'm like oh damn
show she's in a show oh this could be
good because then we could really get a
chance to
you know make her really shine and but
she's kind of just
one of the last things i remembered
about this yeah yeah
when i she is in one episode i'm so
sorry we don't have to
yeah figure this out i care they'll care
about it but it doesn't matter to this
right yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah so
yeah i mean it does seem like one of
those things that they're plucking out
of the past to go like no
see like we we care about this character
that really is just a fun cameo moment
yeah it does
give me some type of hope that may i
think they must
know that some people feel like thor's
band especially sif was kind of slighted
by the handling of the movies and maybe
down the line we could see them more
i could totally see that happening
especially with like to tie it around
to to what you were saying up top you
know about you know you're talking with
your friend and they were sort of
expressing a wish that this was gonna
hop around and get crazy more i feel
like that's the point that we're at now
where like
the next two episodes uh they could just
stay on loki planet but i feel like this
is the point at which things have to pop
off and get crazy
well i feel like they're building to
that they've been building to it yeah
yeah like this really does feel like
every episode is
feels and does something different
like this had the the bleakest of tones
of them all
which when you're looking structurally
like a movie script
it would be at this point you know at
all
this lost moment and then the next next
chapter might be dark night of the soul
and then the finale and the finale is
the finale yeah
um that's kind of how i feel like this
show
has been structured is sort of each
episode has been an act and a giant
movie yeah
yeah that's how it feels for sure which
is awesome
yeah and that makes sense yeah and in a
funny way it almost
to me accounts for some of the responses
to last week because i'm like oh yeah
you were like okay we had this shorter
chapter we had to cut that's mostly
character stuff and yeah you know so we
can make room for this thicker chapter
of like
all the subversions and reveals yeah
because
episode one would be act one episode two
is beginning of act two episode three is
the midpoint like where the character
gets what they've been looking for but
it's not turning out at all like how
they wanted it seems to be going for the
worse
and then we're in the second part of act
two where things start going
much more down and ends with all his
loss moment and darkness yeah it's like
whoa it really is following like a movie
script
if the next episode is the dark night of
the song bam that's what it is
yeah that's cool that's cool well that's
the magic man
long long movies six episodes perfect
length to do that
i should take a page out of that book
yeah man
that that was the kill that's the fatal
flaw in the netflix shows
nobody mastered that six episodes yeah
man
very very true i'm writing my
um justin hammer series oh
yes justice for justin justice for
hammer anyway guys
i give this episode a 9.5 out of 10.
docked at 0.5 for a fight scene that
didn't really need to be crazily
choreographed but i still
very much noticed that it wasn't all
that well done
so 0.5 points deducted john
what are you 9.8 i'll give it a 9.6
just to keep up our you know agreed upon
structure i don't know i'll give it just
a flat 9.5 with you
i'll i'll meet you right on the level
because yeah
like it was a little bit of like a oh
damn we got this cool setting
and you're just gonna no i'm just gonna
wave the things around and
okay amazing how how strong of a point
five
is it's really strong like oh man you
were so close you're so close to being a
10.
but damn you lost 0.5 because
that's okay though it's still got the
job done
oh god i'm confident in you what did we
not talk about that pissed you off that
we didn't talk about leave your
talking about points down below
subscribe click the notification bell
give light to the party some love tell
them we sent you
they paid us nothing no i am furious
about that hey
also at the end of the month we should
shout out some patrons who are pledged
to our uh deleted takes behind the
scenes to your legends
roll that could be clip peter pacheco
joanna saint louis matthew and cern
rogue cree
city94 justin
market kayla waters rosie beatty
darth yoda order 66.
ruby dynamite god
philip j smith jr
jen smith brianna davidson ah
melanie leblanc brittany
by early natalie crow tits dorit
erwin roger chase
partner tayana
eva drastic cuba hey
seriously we rock don't we we're so good
i wonder you guys are pledged to listen
to it makes perfect sense you're
welcome thank you so much for being part
of our patreon page and supporting us at
this level
means a hell of a lot to have you here
you guys are the bomb
the bomb.com ron